hydro québec a reçu le feu vert en avril
pour son deuxième grand projet
d'exportation d'électricité aux états
unis le premier projet vise à acheminer
de l'énergie jusqu'à boston en passant
par le men ce qui va se décider devant
les tribunaux est le deuxième projet
construit sous terre doit fournir d'ici
2026 20% des besoins d'électricité de la
ville de new york et ce projet-là a reçu
un accueil beaucoup plus favorable de la
population vous allez voir c'est mathieu
guillon qui s'est rendu dans l'état de
new york
les new yorkais l'appelle la smaali le
corridor de l'asthme ces jeunes comme
des milliers d'autres dans
l'arrondissement queen's respire l'air
vicié que cacher centrales électriques
aux combustibles fossiles
destiné à alimenter les gratte-ciel
luis au sol nous rencontrent dans
l'épicentre de ce corridor au carrefour
de nombreux logements sociaux raciste
est proche tout prix nos logiciels
il reçoit comme une bouffée d'air frais
la mise en service d'ici 2026 de
l'action à de sunpower express n'est 250
mégawatts d'hydroélectricité québécoise
la ligne souterraine de près de 7
milliards de dollars en partie enfouie
sous le lac champlain partira du post
airtel hydro québec en montérégie et se
connectera ici dans queens au réseau
distribution
new york il est défenseur du projet
espère qu'il contribuera à réduire les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre dans
la métropole et à fermer les centrales
de pointe polluants
les principaux groupes d'intérêts opposé
à la ligne d'hydro-québec dans le
secteur énergétique mais aussi chez les
écologistes ont décliné ou ignoré nos
demandes d'entrevue à commencer par le
propriétaire de cette centrale de
production d'électricité à partir de gaz
naturel et de mazout la plus polluante
de new york rise layton point avait
promis de fermer ces installations
si son projet de ligne pour acheminer de
l'énergie éolienne et solaire était
approuvée mais il a été rejeté au grand
dam du syndicat qui représente les
travailleurs dans l'industrie électrique
[Musique]
et new york times new york state
bien qu'un contrat soit signé avec
l'état de new york hydro québec ne se
dit pas immunisé contre une contestation
judiciaire qui pourrait mettre en péril
son projet comme en nouvelle angleterre
il ya des entreprises qui ont des
management qui se refuse à la transition
énergétique parce que sa menace leur
mois de 9 heures donc immunisés je ne
pense pas aux mène son projet de lignes
aériennes précipité après un refus au
new hampshire en 2018 se heurte à une
forte opposition de la société civile
dans l'état de new york l'action
prennent racine power express est en
développement depuis 2008 et hydro
québec s'est impliqué dans les
communautés versants notamment des
centaines de milliers de dollars à des
organismes de coït ce qu'on vit à new
york est certainement instruit de ce
qu'on a vécu dans le même dans le mail
on sait plus on s'est déployée
différemment on sait déployer un peu
plus tard
mais on s'est déployée quand même avec
les communautés avec des thermopompes
pour autant peut-être trop tard
peut-être trop tard hydro québec mise
gros avec ces deux projets d'exportation
les derniers qu'elle prévoit des revenus
de 50 milliards de dollars sont dans la
balance pour les deux prochaines
décennies et si matthew zions
radio-canada new york pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit
[Musique]